it's a difficult situation for everyone
I know it would be you know everyone
everyone john stamos opening up more
about lorry locklins alleged involvement
in the college admission scandal the
fuller house star is featured inside GQ
September issue where he talks about his
longtime friend and former full house
co-star amid her legal battle he tells
the mag quote honestly I can't figure it
out it doesn't make sense I talked to
her the morning everything hit
I just can't process it still whatever
happened I'm pretty sure that the
punishment is not equal to the crime if
there was a crime just a little
refresher on all that legal drama in
April Laurie and her husband Massimo
pleaded not guilty to the charges they
face for allegedly paying five hundred
thousand dollars in bribes to get their
daughters Olivia and Bella admitted to
USC as recruits for the crew team even
though neither of them participated in
the sport I've said everybody I just
gonna wait a little longer before I can
let me talk about it now John tells the
mag why he's staying tight-lipped about
the whole ordeal quote I gotta be
careful I want to wait until the trial
happens if it does or whatever the
result is and then talk about it
on Tuesday Laurie and Massimo were
photographed leaving the Boston federal
courthouse where they appeared for a
pre-trial hearing about the charges they
face for conspiracy to commit on his
services mail and wire fraud and
conspiracy to commit money laundering
the couple held hands before and after
the 45-minute hearing a judge cleared
the way for the couple to share
attorneys for a United Front strategy I
think given the circumstances of what
they're up against what this trial is
probably the smartest strategy they have
yet because jurors would have to
basically believe that both of them are
lying
and while Laurie is in and out of
courtrooms her fuller house co-stars are
back on set filming the fifth and final
season without Aunt Becky when et caught
up with Candace Cameron Bure in June she
had this to say about Netflix's plans to
address Laurie's absence it hasn't been
discussed I have absolutely no answer
for it and and Netflix has not even
spoken about it this story is obviously
still developing and et will be right
here to bring you all the details so
make sure to keep on coming back for
more until next time I'm Hallie Stevens
bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]